sesamum nah she's also called setna
among other things and she is the
concept for annoyed of sustainable
development she's the keeper of the sea
beast she's the keeper of all animals
that innovate were making a living off
if the human beings that you know it
making not good use of the resources she
can polish they annoy it she's living in
the bottom of the sea the shaman would
go down to the bottom of the sea and
calm her down and ask her what the human
beings have done wrong so he was
communicating a or a mediator between
her and the in women oh that's a story
behind it hey say summer under my name
is Lena Kilson home hey I'm from
Greenland I'm into it you look
originally I'm from South Greenland some
a place called [ __ ] ok I've been living
here looking for the last 25 years I've
been living from working with a annoyed
circumpolar Council but before that i'm
educated there within
I have an academic education from the
University of Greenland where I was
starting culture and history of Inuit
see I say is not only to Green Lantern's
but to innovate see ICASA has a very
deep meaning about the Polar Circle a
you will see doc slits today the hunters
and fishermen are making a living from
the sea ice by using the tops nature's
on on the sea ice this is why it's so
important because they otherwise we
couldn't go anywhere in wintertime you
couldn't go anywhere to fish or hunt if
you didn't have a way of their traveling
when you are talking about the sea ice
but you hear everywhere is that they the
sea ice is developing a later in the
autumn and it is breaking up there
earlier in the spring not only is it a
acting like that the sea ice is also
becoming thinner the hunters were
showing us say what route they used to
navigate on that in the later years or
within the last 10 years they are
changing their roads not only on sea ice
pathology also on on top of the ice caps
that they used to travel on
people are very attached to where they
live and we perceive the world in the
way that we are taught the knowledge
that are handed down to you from your
ancestors are very important and very
quick value and the day you can see that
this knowledge you will no longer be
able to use it that makes I can imagine
that the people will get very touched by
that if you are I in one day or in a
year loses our education educational
skills that we are not any more able to
use the skills that we learned at
University of other educational
institutions this is now I understand
that it is of great importance for them
I would you say that oh I would go there
to help them I don't like the word help
because I'm in with myself and tear of
course a you know it or maybe one people
that are the most
how can you call it researched upon they
know themselves what they learnt they
know themselves that changes are
happening and they know that they will
also have to adapt to the changes the
hunters from Alaska from Canada and
carlock they were able to talk about the
sea ice together and talk about the
changes and ask the right questions and
they have the more answers to the
questions that then we have I know
people knows that they will have to
adapt it but they want to make it in
their own ways of needs yeah at the same
time I'm also a little bit scared our
hunting culture is say stressed to the
edge so it's not only climate change who
are stressing our way out of living it's
also the animal rights organizations and
other organizations
I think that day like I said before
there's been a lot of misunderstanding
and miss miss information about our
culture we are bringing trying to bring
the correct picture out to the world not
only to the outside world but also
within our own society when the sea ice
is gone of course our knowledge about it
would have fun with the melting
you